today we reached an important milestone
in our vaccination campaign 70 of adults
in the european union are now fully
vaccinated and that is more than 250
million people who are immunized and
this is a great achievement
which really shows what we can do when
we work together
but the pandemic is not over and we must
remain vigilant
so first of all we need many more
europeans to vaccinate rapidly
to avoid a new wave of infections and to
stop the emergence of new variants
and i call on everyone who can to get
vaccinated this is the only way to
protect yourself and the others
and secondly
we need to help the rest of the world
vaccinate too
the european union is already doing a
lot
we are exporting and we are donating
vaccines to our partners and we are lead
contributor to covax covax this is our
mechanism
to secure vaccines for low and
middle-income countries
but more needs to be done
and we will continue to support our
partners in this effort
because we will only end this pandemic
if we defeat it in every corner of the
globe
you